okay so two handouts today that are
summaries of previous lectures um
i i gotta start by correcting a typo in
the first in the first
one um
i'm going to get this name right before
the end of the
of the class can we have this on this on
the uh yeah uh her
her la merry claire i thought we got her
first name spelled right but now her
last name has a lowercase v instead of
an uppercase v
um so um
now her i guess her book still hasn't
come into the bookstore but it's
but uh since it's from
random house it ought to be coming in
soon not but i think uh there's a rumor
that both stacy's and printer zinc do
have copies and so
so uh instead of going to the stanford
bookstore there's other bookstores
around it would probably have it
uh but you but uh
uh a little bit more waiting should
should do also
um
now mary claire
is uh
uh has told me a wonderful thing she
will help read your term papers and the
drafts of your term papers
for for to give you feedback so so we're
going to have a real expert
pitching in on the on the grading for
this course
okay now
see anything else old business i i
wanted to talk today about
some experiences on what i call literate
programming and show you uh some of the
ways in which people um
are are groping with
finding a style when you when you're
using a new form of expression
and i think this is kind of interesting
to see the evolution that goes on i know
it certainly happened in my own case
i i spent about um
as i was designing the web system i
spent
uh
well let's see the first test case was
to write web in its own language
and
i so i started out and i and i wrote
about 25 pages of code
um in what i thought webb would look
like then i
uh tore it all up and started over again
but by that time i had developed the
style that seemed to be working and then
i can and of course then i have to
implement the program that's translating
the text i'm writing so there's a
there's a a vicious circle there you
have to have the program before you can
do it now after i had the
program written
by the way i had to had to bootstrap it
i had to first
simulate by hand the computer program
that would
that would take my web program
uh into pascal by by
making a pascal program by hand from my
web specifications and and uh
then
i had to debug that and so and but i i
didn't have to have the whole pascal
program i could leave out the parts that
were
generating error messages or something
that i wasn't going to be using uh on my
first on my you know when web runs
correctly it doesn't generate errors uh
and so i could you know i only had to
implement a subset but i but you start
out and and in order it's a little bit
interesting computer science to figure
out how
how you get web going on a new system if
you have if you have a pascal compiler
uh and a tech processor you should be
able to but let's suppose you only have
a pascal compiler and you wanna and
somebody sends you
some web
web files so including this means you
have a copy of weave web and tangle web
the two the two processors the weave
processor and the tango processor
written in web
but all you all you have is pascal so
you also get a copy of
tangle dot
pascal
the output of
of
of um tangle on itself
and once you've got that then you're in
business because you can then use that
to tangle tangle and with with a few
changes for your own system and you can
use that process that to tangle with
weaving
and then you can get going but as the
bootstrapping process is uh is like all
boost wrapping processes you start out
with uh
a forced uh
you know limited amount of capabilities
that build that gradually build on on
themselves like when you when you boot a
machine
when you uh
when you whenever the machine makes a
cold start
the hardware has um knows how to do
almost nothing at first and then it gets
more and more of its
stuff and so on the same way with that
that's that's uh that's a minor minor
point um now so i was bootstrapping
however
i i
in another sense where i was actually
trying to just
design a system for for illiterate
programming and and so my so i had to
evolve a style of how i was going to
write the program and so on and that and
then uh
after i had
then after i had the web system then i
could
uh start writing tech
the whole process of writing the web
system though was about two months
uh two months of programming it wasn't
it wasn't it wasn't a great slowdown and
then uh
several years to to get tech all
uh refined because of
because tech was supposed to be a
permanent product while web is just a uh
was just an experiment and and there's
many things in web
that are that show the fact that it was
only done in two months and it was never
intended to be a
permanent thing um just as just a
demonstration of what could be done but
i think that
now the experiment has been so
successful that it's been demonstrated
that uh that
program insists programming environments
based on some kind of a
system like this
are are called for and that's what the
current research is doing
well what i want to show you is is how
the undergrads that i worked with last
spring
adapted to this
style of programming and uh
you know some of the some of the painful
changes that must go on when you when
you have one way of writing programs and
then someone tells you now i want you to
write a different way
and some of them did it rather
reluctantly some of them did it very
uh took to it real fast um
and uh it's it's hard for me as the
author of the system to look at it of
course in a in a dispassionate way
um
and i i get uh
you know i get uh various kind of
feedback some of it's very
very pleasing because it's i mean i've
heard of some people said that
hewlett-packard in their division they
started using this way of coding and the
guy said he would never
leave hewlett-packard unless unless it
was for another company that was using
web i mean he thought it was the right
way to program too so well now let me
show you first though an example of one
of the students who
who
probably didn't like it very much
so
so now this each of these programs i'm
showing you is for a slightly different
uh
problem
and uh
the ideas are the students are writing
programs that are going to be that i'm
going to eventually rewrite as part of a
larger project but i wanted to get i
wanted to get their their input and
ideas on
how to how to do it okay this particular
program is is based on five letter words
of english
um
can you zoom up on it a bit more um i i
want to go actually to the top here but
i would like to get this in and pretty
you know this this
up here
uh yeah uh pretty close up on this guy
then i can then i can i can pan it for
there now five letter words uh is one of
the things in this
we're working with in this particular
project we're taking all the i have a
database where i think i have all of the
five letter words of english
and um and i wanted to check that i that
i really that that i really did have
them so i was going to have this guy go
through
all the computer files that we have
of text especially text that i've
written
and look for the five letter words that
appear in there and see how many of
those five other words were not in my
database
so anyway that's the idea of the program
and he starts on first of all at the
beginning
the first paragraph just suffers from
ordinary ideas about english writing
this program reads a list of five other
words and puts them into a dictionary it
then scans an input file of text and
finds the five letter words um
i change it to then it scans an input
file of text and finds the five hyphen
letter words
because you know he hyphenated five
other words in the pre in the previous
sentence he should hyphenate five right
and all that um
so standard uh ideas of english go in
here and then there's a problem about
the it not being uh
it checks to see if the word is in the
dictionary or if it has already
uh been found by the program and so
um
you know that it wasn't too clear so if
the words in the dictionary or if the
word has already been found by the
program
and then it says if it isn't in either
list i said a word that isn't in either
list
is added to the list of words fund found
and all this now um
okay so at the beginning our
introductory paragraph
uh just ordinary writing there
um
now
uh
then we got to the uh
begin to to actually start using web and
this and so
he um
has something where he's called size of
word with caps i i took i said here uh
i
made that symbol which means go to lower
case
but
i now see i misunderstood him he's
talking about
probably a string called word which is
defined down here and so uh what what i
should have told him to do here was
really uh
put put
vertical lines in his file which would
which would mean that then
typographically this would mean the the
variable the program variable word which
would then go into it into italics
um
and uh but uh now the the uh
uh
as i told you the other day the idea of
of web
is that you that you used
you
stick in one module for another like
here you see this types goes in
and variables and the main program gets
stuck in
and then you describe those separately
in the part in a part where it's
convenient for exposition
um
now um
this but uh
you know person was was still using
was still writing a pascal program and
still thinking of it as a pascal program
and not getting the idea of how to
present a program in this in this form
and so um
really there's very little difference in
this
exposition
other than an ordinary one so he starts
out and he finds types and then he says
these are the global variables
now let me explain
about the advantage of not doing it this
way
which of course
then he understood
on his next draft um
the let me i guess the best way to show
you is to show you the exact example of
this this this is uh the largest program
that i that i've done with this style
and it's uh
how many
parts all together let's see
what is it 14 13
thirteen hundred and sixty
seventy six uh
uh parts to it
and um
and i believe that uh there are now
uh hundreds of people in the world who
have gone through this rather
rather thoroughly and understand this
program quite quite well
and
the
it's a long program but still
it's possible to present
even this this and even the for short
program the same kind of thing happens
but in this case there's something i
call global variables
but
if you go to module 13 it's not going to
be a list of all the global variables in
the program
instead
you can keep introducing global
variables
anywhere you feel like another global
variable and so
let's look at section 20 for example
section 20 is where i get some some some
global variables now this is a feature
of web i didn't talk about on monday
and that is that you can have many
different
sections
with the same name so section 20 is got
this name the the pascal code in section
20 is global variables the pascal code
in section 13 was global variables and
the first
and they they all get collected into the
program in this in in one place but you
you keep on adding to this part of the
program every time you you have another
global variable you want you would you
introduce a new new global variable
and so when when the when a person
reading your your program
is is psychologically ready to know that
that another variable is going to be put
in there then you tell them okay by the
way here's here's a global variable that
we're going to put in and that's one of
the features of the web tangle system
that this will get
concatenated will be added on to all the
other things that were
were mentioned
as called global variables so
so uh uh you can in other words there's
a question of motivation there and the
whole idea is to try to present a
program in a form that um
that a reader is ready to pick up the
idea of the of that part of the program
um
this is quite different from the form
that you present to a to a
to a pascal compiler the pascal first
you tell the pascal compiler you list
all your global variables
but the pascal compile you don't have to
motivate the pascal compiler it'll do
this you know it'll it's just not not
getting uh yeah in fact
the psychology of computer programs is a
little bit interesting because everybody
thinks that when they get to the
to the parts of their program that were
hardest to write the machine slows down
a little bit when it gets there because
it's hard to understand what it's doing
you know but you know but uh
in fact when you when you look at the
running time statistics
most of the time machines are doing
things that that you didn't spend much
time
writing like uh and it's just uh but you
have a bad a false we have a false
conception of where our
where our computer programs are
are spending their uh our our uh are
working and we think
almost always that um
uh that the that the computer is most is
ninety percent of the time working on
the part that was hardest for us to
write but really ninety percent of the
time it's passing over blank spaces in a
comment or something like this that was
true that was trivial we never even
thought about
um
well uh
anyways the psychology of it
for for a
a a reader
is
is what we're trying to do when we
present the program and it turns out
that this is almost always
about the same way in which you as when
you wrote the program had to make the
decisions
about the time when you were writing the
program and decided to have a global
variable name something is about the
time that somebody reading the program
is going to want to know
uh that there should be this this this
this global variable or whatever
decision other decision you're making
about a data structure so on so the this
stream of consciousness order
presentation
of how of how to present the the program
to a reader that the reader can
understand what the program does is is
rather close i believe to the order in
which you actually made those decisions
yourself as you were writing the program
and
i find that
as i was writing this long you know 1400
module program um it was
always
fairly clear to me that i had to do in
one of the next
that i had to go in a certain order that
that a certain module had to be the next
one to do i didn't have very much choice
in my own mind as to what to do next
even though it goes on and on for 500
and some pages
um
i i knew that i wanted to do first the
uh
the uh printing routine and then error
the routine that would print out error
messages and then routines for data
structures
somehow that order was forced on me it
was just the natural
the natural question to to ask myself
how am i going to do this as i write the
program and
a reader who wants to read and
understand the program it's also the
thing that the reader should next wants
to know next uh very very closely i
think in most cases
so uh but here's here's an example where
a web isn't being used it's just this
just being used as a formatter for for
for making uh somewhat better comments
but
but the order of presentation hasn't
been hasn't been locked uh hasn't been
caught here um and and uh
you see also here's a two right braces
on separate lines here uh indicating
that uh
um
he
is used to putting comments on two lines
and
forgets that a formatter might be able
to get that all in one line or choose
the best line break
okay now let's see
so i'm starting out with showing you the
learners experiences
with this and uh
a minor problem here is uh
put a hyphen at the end of a line in the
word processor i thought that you know
always put the space after that too um
but let's see what i wanted to mention i
guess
is um
a problem of exposition that's in
general for for how do you describe a
computer of a computer
behavior
computer program uh
are
are we running the
is is the is the program off there
running itself some automaton doing the
thing or are are we part of the action
are we are we participating in the
program somehow
uh
that's livelier to do to put us into in
the picture
um
and so probably we get
there's a
so probably so here you see see if we
have already found this word in this in
this file
and it says
if we have not it puts the word into the
list okay
now you know he was a dilemma in his
mind which way it was going to be but i
think you go with we on this uh when
you're when you're part of the program
uh i think we're participating so it's
not only a dialogue
author and reader as a team here but
really we're also collaborating with
that we're we're also
carrying out the algorithm as we're as
we're doing it i think
and so
um so see if we have already found this
word in the file so i rewrote it saying
if
not we put the word into the list of new
words found
okay and then we say we keep finding
five letter words and checking them
until the end of the file in is reached
okay so
now
another thing
in this style of programming
uh one of the main ideas of
uh
i guess the main idea was to understand
a complicated thing
locally by understanding
uh each part uh and then how those parts
relate to each other one and one of the
keys then is to put a name into each
part so here we have a name of the main
program and then that invokes other
parts one called
uh puts the word into the dictionary and
here was one called store the new word
in the list of newer now you know we
should try to think of a style that's
consistent here
puts the word into the dictionary as a
uh is it oh i what's the proper
technical word for this uh it's a you
know it's a
it's a description or something that
puts the word in the dictionary but here
we have a definite imperative store you
know it starts out with a with a verb
uh saying do it and i i i think that
that tends to work out best uh say put
the words in the dictionary so
so i would start out with an imperative
and uh it seemed to be best for me to
capitalize it in that case uh
like the main program now the main
program was not a
an imperative it was a decl it was it
was it was declarative
um
and uh
there's different parts of the of the
code that are imperative and and
declarative for example global variables
that's declarative you're declaring
global variables
but when you
so you so if you want to be imperative
you'd say do the main program but the
main program is really a piece of texas
and it's a it's a declarative thing
something is there
but when you start out with an
imperative verb you're saying this is a
bunch of commands
that are that are being executed so i
think it's a good
a good idea to to have that
a convention that you start out with
with a imperative verb when you
when uh the module in question is
these commands start out and but start
out with something you know domain
program something just plain old
declarative just give a noun uh when
it's uh uh when really the the module
consists of a piece of text that sort of
has the has a declarative function
although the main program then
the text actually is actions
um
the uh
uh
there's a way to to have order what long
identifiers now he's got things called
out file info get word find in dick find
in new words
and
a lot of times people use a convention
in their
in their text files now when you have a
long compound identifier made up of
several words
to
capitalize each word afterwards so that
you get in so that you can see where
they where they break up well this one
of course was a little inconsistent
there this finding was would put an eye
in there
personally i find that that that that
looks bad typographically when these
these fonts of type that have revolved
over many years were never intended for
a uppercase letter to be following a
lowercase letter and it doesn't and they
don't really look very good in that in
that way it's not not too bad on a
typewriter and a terminal when um but
um
so anyway i uh the web system has a has
a way to
to make compound words that looks better
typographically i believe and we'll see
a lot more examples of it where you
would actually would actually say get
word with a little line in between tying
the tying the two together now pascal
doesn't allow this little line
as part of
the name of an identifier
but tangle takes it out
and
but it's
you can put it there in your input file
and uh it tends to make the program look
better i think a lot better when you
have a when you have a compound
name and
and i think you do need compound names
so
it's impossible to uh
to find one word always that will
describe everything in a long program
and along in fact some people uh i think
it was this was a innovation of the
digitech
the people
it's called digitech corporation who
made a lot of waves in the early 60s by
having the best compilers on the market
and their style of programming was
to have identifiers that were about 40
characters long
and each but each one was sort of a
short story telling you exactly what
all the invariants and everything were
encoded in identifier and whenever you
and i don't know how they
got the typos to type all these things
over and over again but uh but it was
very clear reading the code was what it
what what the meaning of every variable
was
uh that was uh
an extreme but
uh and then they didn't write any
comments in their code at all
um
okay so that's
that's this now let's see um
so i would
i would give i would have called this
word
underline list uh as a better choice the
name i think
um
okay
now
but
evidently the
capitalization means nothing to this
person because here's a ch and a ch of
both caps and they must
mean the same
the same one now the comment that i gave
him at this one this module is
completely unmotivated at this place
also it's misnamed as it merely skips
over blank so that so the
the uh all of a sudden in the middle of
this after presenting um
after presenting two things here which
was fairly good i mean storing a new
word is during an old word this was
fairly reasonable parallelism um
uh except there was no period there but
anyway it was parallelism uh but then
all of a sudden we have another a new uh
something which is called skip to the
beginning of the next word and and if
you look at the code it says
it just looks it skips over blanks
now
we're looking we're reading an arbitrary
text file and
the words in this text file are going to
be
this is going to be a technical concept
word
means something that is preceded by a
non-letter and followed by a non-letter
or something like that i mean a word
doesn't have to you know there's besides
spaces there's punctuation marks
parentheses and all kinds of things in a
file that aren't part of a word and so
um when you say if you would say skip to
the beginning of the next word you're
talking about a technical thing
a word uh a five letter word that you're
looking for in the file and uh
this would
that would then you would then skip over
more than just blanks but this is
something that just skips over
blanks and it also uh
uh
has another problem with with pascal
that it assumes things that a lot that
some pascal compilers will
will do differently than others if we're
writing
portable code but that's another subject
so there's no point in putting this
module here
until we're ready for it so okay well
now let's see um
this was a uh
uh this was
example of engineers the poor i mean
this module read a word from the word
file and stores it in the dictionary it
does absolutely no error
checking and assumes each word is all
lower case no punctuation there and
everything that was out there was just
uh glitchy english but um but then it
was okay and this the comment in the
next part here was this module zips
through the hash table printing out all
the words in each bucket
that made sense to in the context of the
of the thing
well
now
finally we get to the part of the
program where it says finding the next
next five letter word and this is where
i was expecting i would find the the
formal definition
stated informally of what is a a word
when we talk about five other words in
this program the whole point of this
program there should be some part of the
text which says what what it is but no
that was all left to you had to read it
from the code to smoke out what the idea
is of a of a quote word unquote so
so um the the main part of the
documentation was
what was missing here
um
and uh instead uh the
uh the
the uh his his idea of what
documentation should be is to give a
play-by-play account
um
saying um
you know so here it is you see it's like
uh
uh it finds the next five letter word if
it reaches the end before it finds the
final word it retunes the booming valley
false
it first checks if it's at the end of a
line if so it does such such if not it
does this reads it converts if the if it
is a letter it does this if it is not
and so on
it exits this loop while it comes so
it's this is a
a transcription of of a of an algorithm
into uh
into
words but it's
but it'd be better to give the intuition
it would be better to give a high level
rather than a play-by-play
in this part to set the scene for it the
play-by-play can be anybody can
understand the if and i mean
much easier reading code than by reading
a whole bunch of if stands and and
and things like that what you want here
is the feeling for what's going on i
think so so um
misconception now here's another thing
about this module is too long you
haven't discovered why web is good yet
okay so here we have a whole page of
code
um and uh that's that's it now the the
idea in in web is
to break a complex thing down into small
parts
and uh and ideally about a maximum of a
dozen lines of code in every part
so
this this this whole box in here for
example i would call
a new module i call read from the file
until coming to the end or to a word of
the correct size say something like that
and then that would be up that would be
you could read then this this function
get word and you would
be able to understand the function get
word as a unit then if you want to find
out exactly what it does when it's
reading from the file then we go into
this other module read from the file and
we get to see it in in place
now but here's
here's a strange thing and i still don't
know what happened but here i say oh my
you've really broken weave this is all
formatted
wrong i know my
i have never seen
my program do this before and so somehow
he he must have inserted
line breaks in his program or something
that would
have that would
would cause the then to be on a separate
line from the if and
and the begins aren't lining up right
everything is broken and i have no idea
i've never seen this happen before and i
see and the only way you can do that is
by
putting little hidden commands inside
saying uh
do something unusual and and uh so
anyway so that's all broken there
um
well
uh that was one so i was a bit
discouraged when i saw that first one
but uh things got better
now another student here
um
this uh
this brings up some more
some more points about about uh
the use of a new of a new system um
one of the one of the uh
special things is that there's
there's a a module can be given a title
that's going to carry over for several
other modules and then that becomes a
sub head at the top like the program or
something use it here but uh but the
very first module the student didn't use
it could have said introduction or
something like that so instead we just
got a sort of a default uh subhead at
the top
so i just suggest write that but now
here's here's something more interesting
i think um
he says given a file name xxx dot yyyy
it will create a reverse file xxxx.rev
and these are all caps
maybe boldface i don't know but it
doesn't look right in that font um this
is a variable width font and
and really it would have been it would
if you had written it in a typewriter
style it would have come out looking
like some like like the name of a file
to me
okay so
now
so this is a case where using the
typewriter style of type which which is
is there would would be a better
uh
you know better convention for referring
to something that's a name of a file
which is something that that is a
definite a typewritery um
thing
um
now again this was this this is a
freshman here who's writing his first
short program in web
and uh i'm expecting to find lots of
things of course because i told them to
just do something and let me criticize
it i didn't i didn't tell them to spend
much time polishing or anything i don't
get the wrong idea here
the first uh the modules here one was
called variables one was called type and
then i you know i said make them both
plural if you're gonna do that
um
now
oh goodness what were they going to say
here there's a bunch of things but um
i don't want to get into
into unnecessary stuff here was a case
again where where a long piece of code
could be broken very nicely into two
into two modules so when i put this line
around this business here this me this
said this would now become a modulus
another module called read the next line
of input into data of counter and append
a percent sign
and then that would be the
then that module would do it it would
read the next line into it and then
there would be a corresponding one write
data as a new line of output
and and then i suggested there would be
a parallel way to make it elegant code
or something to look for anyway well
um
so
that was simply a case of taking a large
piece of code then finding a small part
that could be understood as a unit and
and uh and unifying it
the
the this person had a has a convention
that when he writes uh when he gets to
the an end he says in a comment saying
what kind of thing has ended end of a
while end of a while end of a four
statement end of a while and so on those
comments are are no longer
necessary when you have the web system i
think
because the indentation makes it clear
what's ending at the
at this point
um
so
the so there are places where you
you know that where you've used in your
other in your other uh uh
form of programming you the conventions
were developed which were appropriate to
that style because they got around some
of the
problems of
of of that style of programming but then
those solutions are no uh you know
they're just excess baggage when you
bring over to another style often
okay
uh here's here's another kind of a
something that i i should mention
sometime in this course and that is when
you when you're communicating with a
user
this is another kind of uh
mathematical writing or technical
writing all your messages that go out to
on the terminal and back in that's
that's that's language and so on think
about style of
of uh
of of of communicating and uh so here i
i you know this is name of file to
reverse please and so on and then that's
a prompt and and uh it's reasonable
um and i was just saying what about what
if you said
what file shall i reverse something like
that or should i reverse
um
and that's another way to uh
to prompt a user
uh that i wanted to discuss a little bit
uh using first person the computer is
talking as if it's as if it's an animate
object and says i
you know
and um
uh
some people think this is a very uh
almost immoral to have to have computers
personified
i think dijkstra is very
against any kind of anthropomorphic use
language
with respect to computers
but i think it's it it's very effective
and uh
and i always think of uh
when i'm when i'm not talking about the
protocols or something it's
much easier to think about handshaking
and this guy says something to that guy
instead of
instead of saying this process says
something that process it doesn't it
doesn't make any sense you know it's
much more easy for me to conceptualize
um alice and bill making an
exchange than than two of two abstract
processes and
so i anyway i go
for uh using first person in in
communication with uh
with users
uh as a
recommendation that i think works nice
uh some people might be offended though
of course the eliza program and these
things
were
did this and fooled everybody uh they
would
you would say you know this you know
what i mean the program that the doctor
is in now and then you and you and it
says please state your problem and then
it says i understand and
you know and all this
and um
um
what
yes right right that's right and and
then it quotes this x from your previous
sentence and everything in the eye so
you so it makes it seem as though
there's more going on here you know you
can be you can certainly uh
you know pull magic tricks this way uh
but but you can also do this more
effectively than than sticking to only
on the abstract stuff
okay now here's a case of starting a
starting a sentence with a symbol
um
uh data is the name of a variable here
and so it says data assumes that no
nullify will be more than 5 000 lines
long which to me appears far more than
enough
so i just added a few words the big data
array assumes that no and so on because
in pascal you have to declare the size
of your arrays
so again it seemed to be jarring to
start out the sentence with a lowercase
letter and starting out with a symbol
now
now the
the second program this person this
freshman wrote was
was very
pleasant for me to to read
because he had he has a unique style
which which very which very well came
through in his in his writing
um
and you'll see you'll see that as we in
the next minute or two um
he starts out and he says hmm let's see
what we need to put in the main body and
all this you know so he's he's uh
um
he's given you the stream of
consciousness all right
um
now
one thing that
that was uh clearly could be could be
improved in this particular starting
point was he started he had module one
the main body and then that was it
there's nothing nothing there
um
and so um
you should start out and say something i
mean what so you say this program does
what so you know you want to have some
kind of introduction and then i would
that then i would put that as the pascal
text to the to to module one which has
no has nothing so there should be
something there and then and then these
other things these definitions which are
which define conventions that are used
elsewhere uh
for example counts is is a synonym for
it's a macro it's a synonym for count
one comma count two but that
it's not motivated at the moment uh uh
so but but he gives a comment that says
the following are defined for ease of
reading and writing the program that's
the motivation but that comes after the
program comes first and then
and you know so this this part of the
thing should belong in module one and
then these definitions nice in module
two here i suggested a better name for
this he called it range but range is not
very descriptive that could mean
anything so i why not call it caps or
caps range because he's defining a range
of capital letters things like that
okay
now um
he
uh
um
is implementing a rather complicated
procedure here
and i don't i'm not going to go into
that but i want to
but he has things called the brain he
says well let's try and see if we can
read in the data and set up a graph
okay
see where we're going to do it now that
we have the meat of the program down
let's get to the nitty nitty-gritty
um
so
the the his personality was certainly
coming through in
in the style
says
aha two more variables
while you would have to go all the way
back to the var section in ordinary
pascal
you all we do in web is add them right
here
it says how about a web programming
contest in which you are unable to back
up in the program
okay so
and here i i just commented that's the
best expert
exposition of a program except for
people who who you know especially for
people who never get better ideas and
throw and throw stuff away
but uh but anyway he was he was
realizing at this point that he could
declare a variable right here where he
wanted to and he didn't have to go back
and put it in
he says well this is great but we have
to initialize hash table to some sort of
initial value since i have more cells
than the number of characters in most
reasonable books that will mark those
and so on so
um but he
uh
he got he got his the feeling of uh
of enthusiasm into this better than
anybody else i've seen in a program
um
his program is called components
but at the beginning but the name of the
program here is compliments and uh
and i wondered why he called it
compliments and finally i
i found out that
they're both the same for him compliment
and component are the same and so i told
him that
i better that i had to warn him that
those words are slightly different
okay
now
the asterisks here got up high if he had
used the typewriter style asterisk it
would have been it would have been down
lower and looked more like an asterisk
that you would see in a in in a text
file
um
that's just a minor point but astr but i
think when you're communicating about
computer programs that's uh it's
worth noting that asterisk
uh
is uh in on
a
computer terminal is tends to be
download you know centered like the
letter c or something like that but if
it's an asterisk that's in it in a
standard font
of type that you get from a typesetter
right as opposed to a computer terminal
asterisk it tends to be way up high
and if you've only got one
um
in the font then uh it's it's
tends to be problems that is uh uh you
find when you start computer science
writing that you're marking all the
askers to be lowered to the printer if
you if you don't have if they don't
already have a body centered asterisk
here's a here's a cute thing i had never
seen
in an exposition before and i i'm not
recommending it but i just thought it
was cute i wanted it it says it goes
down a list of characters that we have
used and it says print
remember
a double star question mark why
so in other words it he's got this
prompt and he always also answers it
with a y here so he's
talking computers very self-consciously
but uh he's still kind of cute
um
okay
oh oh we've just introduced several more
variables better declare them all are
pretty trivial i trust the general
reader to understand their use
this is not a good thing to trust the
general reader to i mean
i have a general rule that whenever you
declare a variable
always give a comment about what the
significance of that variable is even if
the name of the variable is rather
self-descriptive this is the best place
for a comment that's sort of an informal
invariant about what that variable
satisfied
sometimes the variable is is really just
so trivial that it doesn't deserve a
comment and then you just say you know
temporary temporary variable for
manipulation or something but i would
still say that in a comment
um
but if it's a count you would say you
know this is how many names there are or
something not just a counter but you
would say you know something that
describes what the what the variable
means
uh always give a always give a comment
whenever you define our variables
all right now another freshman
first use of web
has a program that was processing
the mona lisa in an interesting way
and uh
um
this program reads a data file a
digitized version of the famous mona
lisa painting which is considered to be
a single undirected graph and he
explains in which in which way
i mean has rows and columns and that's
an instance matrix and and make a graph
out of it well
um
now here
here is an asterisk used for
multiplication uh uh it doesn't work
very well i mean a
high asterisk up there for
multiplication anyway even if it were
down low we better replace it by a
multiplication sign i think
and then you would say rows here of
course is because you're saying columns
in
in order to be consistent
um
here's this per se
using the the style here he decided that
the title of every module would be used
with all caps i mean capitalize
uh capitalize every uh
every word after the first one now
that's just
something that's difficult to do
automatically capitalize the word and
too usually if we're capitalizing
something in mixing caps and lower case
we
in a title we would we would take the
most common words like of and
and things like that and not capitalize
them
and when you get newspaper headlines and
stuff things like that except i guess
they have a rule
that if you start a new line you break
the headline into two lines and the
second line starts with and you still
capitalize to and sometimes a lot of
people i don't know
um
but it didn't work too well in web
programs like i suggest not doing that
just capitalize the first the first one
which seemed to be it seemed to work
well to have it to have it i
experimented with with both ways
and capitalizing the first one seemed to
work not putting a period at the end
seemed to be seen to be good but not
capitalizing the whole work
scene two words
um
here's another point about this goes
into ordinary technical writing here's
talking about bytes
now when we and hexadecimal uh
decimal notation now here's a here's
another place where fonts can help in
exposition if you're writing hexadecimal
typewriter type turns out to be a nice
code for saying this is a hexadecimal
number if you if uh you know so if you
see if you see a use of typewriter type
for a number
you might know that that's base 16
automatically
um
but now he did he he started he had he
had it right at the beginning but then
he should have put the 63 in roman so
here he has the three f this is in
typewriter style he says 3f represents
63 that 63 should be ordinary roman in
decimal so the normal decimal type
start normal decimal numbers in normal
in normal type but
but when you say double f represents
light double zero represents black
that those are in in typewriter
indicating these are
these are hexadecimal digits
um
okay
worthwhile
typewriter type to seems to have a nice
machine oriented function to it that
helps helps distinguish
itself here now here's a a matter of
exposition
um
we
he's got this is a fairly good-sized
program it's about fifth
57 modules
and
it's trying to look at the pic it's
essentially it has 90 000 pixels of mona
lisa and it's trying to
pick out the darkest ones i i think
in the whole array and so it's using a
heap for this uh
uh
the heap the kind of heap that means
used for a priority queue so that you
can you can find the
the thousand
largest elements in the heap that you
know you don't you don't store all the
pixels in memory but you only store the
currently largest ones in this kind of
data structure called the heap and so he
has this as at this point in this
program he's mentioned that he's going
to keep uh use a heap for his data
structure
and uh now he's defined it and he got
we've got the data structure for it but
then it turned then
then the program goes on and talks about
a complicated graph theory algorithm and
then finally when we get to module 52 or
something we go and do a sword on the
heap
and uh this is uh
you know the the reader of the program
is all geared up and understands heaps
right now so it would work it worked out
better to get through while this was
fresh in in mind
to do that part of the program that's
going to use the heap at this point and
you can do that with web you can you can
put you can put code in
um
at any point you don't have to write top
down
uh or bottom up or any other order you
can you can write in whatever order you
think is right for exposition and and
the the web system is going to put the
program together into into the order
that that the machine needs it later on
so you so at this point it would be it
would be a good idea to give the
algorithm for heap sort
now however you get a problem that is um
uh the sort routine calls
one of the in his in his program his
sort routine has has a call on another
procedure called ad edge which isn't
declared yet i mean which is going to be
part of his graph
graph theory algorithm and we're not
ready to understand that that at all yet
we have to push that down um so uh how
do you how do you do that well in web
you can you can
insert like uh in here under procedures
and function you can insert the sorting
procedure as a separate module and say
and then that'll get put in before the
other procedures
that i mean i mean it'll you can put you
can call it the sorting procedure and
call that here the instead of procedures
and functions used and added to that
part of the program you just call it the
sorting procedure and then you'll be
guaranteed that the sorting procedure
will come last after the other
procedures that it actually calls
and when we get to that part of the of
the procedure there's it's it would be
easy to here's the sorting procedure and
it'd be easy to take this part of it and
replace it by something called
use the largest element of the heap to
add an edge to the graph
then this module would have some number
to it like it would have a number 50
which would
show the reader this is coming up later
after we understand what it means to add
an edge to the graph
um but and and we could then understand
this much of it perfectly well while
we're well we know what a heap is
about sorting and we wouldn't have to
mix all the things together in our minds
and do and we could we could get the
heap stuff out of the way
once and for all
okay um
the uh
um
one of the problems about documentation
is that
that
it should actually it
it should actually
um uh
match the formal
the formal thing so here he has a
variable called avail but in his
documentation he calls it a
um and that can be confusing i mean if
you know so you gotta you gotta make
sure there's nobody checking that this
informal description actually matches
the formal one
okay now
let's see anything else here
um
not too important there
okay nothing terribly important here the
these two modules are really the same so
there's no reason to
to
just to have two separate modules for
that
but i had a more important thing oh yeah
here
as a matter of style in web
um
i found that it was generally bet when i
have a the name of a module like join
isolated vertices it would be good to to
to start that code with the word begin
and end it code with the word n instead
of saying begin and then join isolated
vertices and then end around you know
instead of putting the beginning end
around the the call of the that code put
that code you know put it inside the
code because the syntactically it looks
like joint isolated vertices is a unit
and if you if you didn't have a
beginning in there and you just wrote it
in here it would look like you know
because these brackets here look like
parenthesis it looks like it's got to be
an end around it you'd have a terrible
bug
because uh
pascal would only you know would only
associate the first uh
this the first statement here with the
with the if if then and it would and uh
you would you would read through this it
would look like it's saying something
other than it really does so make this a
general convention on myself that i put
a beginning in uh inside the modules now
of course if i had a programming system
if web
were not being patched on top of pascal
and i was really using a programming
environment
my programming environment would do this
for me it would it would make sure that
i wouldn't make such errors i have to i
have to use that discipline but it
certainly makes a better looking
exposition to put the beginning end
inside than it than outside
oh
i'm sorry they uh
i went way over time i'm very sorry
today so uh
uh
see you friday
you